warning robots were harmed in the making
of this video this little bug like robot
is pretty nifty at walking but what
happens if a mean scientist comes along
and breaks one of its legs most robots
will just try and fail to keep walking
in the same old way but this guy's
different
it can learn to adapt its walking style
just like an animal would it tries out
different things until it can get back
on the move here's what it settled on
pretty speedy in slow motion you can see
this robots new walk is pretty bouncy
compared to its original stroll it chose
this walking style from thousands of
options researchers had programmed into
it and it only took 40 seconds to work
it out the robot can adapt to many
different injuries this time one of its
legs has been snapped off it's not easy
moving with only five legs after just 25
seconds though the robots back on the
move even faster than before it may seem
cruel to this little robot but robots
can be far more versatile if they can
get back on their feet after they've
been injured
you